well welcome
welcome to your mom's house Christina
the gypsies the black community is
talking so much shit about Birdman's
keep my name ATLA tomorrow
Marlon Wayne everyone I thought of it
first
oh shit farts on my wagon see room I
finalize she's oh I'm gonna told you
about you did but I had seen and I
didn't know what it was and then I'd
seen it now listen to me
I saw those posted I was telling you
about this and you're like wait what
minute what I saw it on Instagram but I
didn't understand bird man I know who it
was and I just saw a lot of people
talking shit on him remember I know I've
seen it but I hadn't put it together
until he told me how why would I lie cuz
you're a born liar have no idea that's
not I saw it but I didn't understand it
cuz it's gonna happen was it went in
here and then here is nothing happened
and then now you're like I've been on
top of this sort okay I hope you enjoy
being single hey right now you need me
the most no are you reminding yourself
DJ be the most we should talk about this
on the show the burger can you play it
babe
of course I think I would not have that
ready to go
so more abuse analysis mm with use yeah
that's a finding somebody's like
Christine looks like she's paying bills
but she that's just because I'm always
right oh my god what I started writing
because I figure it looks better than me
looking
that's mine Elster in here so ridiculous
yeah we'll put that birdman thing here
to the fuck bet I don't know first of
all I still know who it is I don't know
it is I saw it on Instagram because I
follow like Marlin lands and he had
posted something about it and I was like
that's weird that's a weird thing and
then you brought it up later and I was
tired and connected awesome two-layer
why would I lie about this there's no
reason for me to hide it I just didn't
see Benny god I love you so much you're
so lucky I'm serious what why plums our
husband as much as me it's like an
ancient what why should you make you
breakfast today I made you breakfast
when 2009 time you made me breakfast
Hagar that's not true yuh-huh Yoho when
I was nursing her baby like two months
ago you did 11780 eggs yeah make it
breakfast last week okay cool cool we do
that coffee drinking